[Music]
a little update on infinite spiral reps
I for a long time had issues with
infinite spiral wraps I could kind of do
them yeah and I even made a video on how
to do them but you know what they were
never yeah I mean it was never like
Booya my runs what was missing and it's
this they work the best when the way you
hold the poi has deploy attached to the
back of your hands and your knuckles at
least that's how they work for me
because as in my other video we go over
they go around your wrists and then
comes together and if the poi are
attached to your wrist knuckle side of
your hand they go an equal amount around
wrists before they spiral around you're
connected hence so in the past I'd
always used to grip like this where I
was kind of and I would put my hands
like this that's my that's the way I
would typically do a spiral wrap and
that works really well but it doesn't
work for infinite spiral wraps because
when I do this my right poi is a little
more wrapped that than my left that
makes it go squish flop so if I switch
and I'm for now it's gonna use this
that's a simple way to show so I'm just
holding a boy like that when I go into a
spiral wrap that way it goes bump bump a
nice boppity-bopping if your spiral rep
so of course I could also do wrap wrap
and do more and you know it was years
that I could do them pretty well but I
thought you know maybe I just learned
them too late maybe I had to be younger
when I learned in for the spot wraps to
do them like Dan did them etc um no just
my grip
live from effigies Canada video co-hosts
emmechelle chica Nick we'll see
[Music]